tell me about this AJ Rodriguez
plays the show you streamer he picked up
one of my cars he was playing with me I
sucked with him but every time he would
face somebody I'd go crazy you like
can't escape him like robbing a home run
right and he's saying he'd get so mad
because it was like dude when I give you
that opportunity on my team you don't do
nothing I just all of a sudden go online
or go on Twitter or whatever and I just
see him popping up it's Cedric wallets
again that's Cedric Mullins again all I
can do is laugh when I finally met him
he's like bro you like jump-started my
career and I was like sure you kind of
did the same for me because it really
just kind of blew both of us up no he's
cool for sure